on va passer à guillaume 33 ans policier
à la bac vice-président du mouvement des
policiers en colère policiers c'est la
profession où l'on se suicide le plus où
il ya le plus de suicides 30% de suicide
en plus depuis le début de l'année par
rapport à 2018 les heures de nuit sont
très mal payés 97 centimes
guillaume cc c'est incroyable vous êtes
fatigué n'est pas celle week-end de
repos faut savoir que vous avez un
week-end de repos sur six en temps
normal mais en temps normal donc centré
sur la conjoncture du pays
le repos sorcier ça arrive souvent
qu'ils sautent à ccc ccc en théorie et
mais n'avait pratiquement pas de
week-end alors vous votre proposition
elle est simple elle est claire et elle
concerne bien sûr tous les policiers
parce qu'aujourd'hui on a essayé de
représenter le maximum de personnes
possible parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
en souffrance et vous je sais guillaume
que c'est compliqué pour vous tous les
jours guillaume juste pour savoir vous
êtes policier à la bac est ce que parce
qu'aujourd'hui voilà est-ce que c est ce
que je peux vous demander combien vous
gagnez par mois de travail en fait moi
personnellement je suis prêt quel cette
police d'accord c'est en région
parisienne donc je maximum de prime par
rapport au salaire soit 2300 euros
2300 des collègues qui font le même
travail que moi oui ils sont agents de
sécurité qui sont engagés qui font la
même mission et qui sont smic d'accord
d'accord donc savary et vous travaillez
vous travaillez sept jours sur sept
pratiquement à 20 quand on fait tous les
amplitudes horaires 7 sur 7 a fait que
siri gagner c'est juste au dessus de
gardienne de la paix en dessous du sous
officier en dessous deux chefs 1
exactement le président
alors guillaume quel est votre
proposition moi j'aime trop la
composition c'est pour améliorer le
quotidien des fonctionnaires de police
chez comme l'a rappelé est honneur hayat
a on a onze collègues maintenant qu'ils
sont suicidés depuis le début d'année
2010 9 on a onze suicides dans la police
et la situation n'est plus tenable 32
policiers sont suicidés en 2018 en 32
ans du 10 mai donnent déjà 11 en 2011 à
9,6 de ce début d'année
voilà donc le chiffre est alarmant et
aujourd'hui je voudrais en profiter pour
tirer la sonnette d'alarmé parce que
parce que ça va plus dans nos rangs des
non plus que des années ce problème et
malheureusement les partis en
considération le procès le précédent
ministre de l'intérieur n'a pas mis en
oeuvre des actions concrètes le
gouvernement précédent non plus
on compte beaucoup sur le gouvernement
actuel en fait pour enfin nous entendre
parce qu'on est une petite association
de policiers en colère et on essaie de
remonter toutes les informations du
terrain
en fait moi je sur le terrain aussi et à
la parole qu'on va vous livrer en fait
c'est la parole directe du terrain n'y a
pas de filtre ya pas de filtre de la
hiérarchie a pâti de son petit gars vous
avez des contacts déjà avec la lune et
les ministres malheureusement non au
vert du jaune a refusé de recevoir on a
fait beaucoup de lettres au ministre de
l'intérieur et on regrette
malheureusement que il ya des filtres
entre nos lettres et le ministre on
n'arrive pas à le toucher
vous avez une lettre avec vous je peux
peut-être remettre à christophe de l
ornière votre lettre voix nous on
aimerait bien effectivement il faut vous
remettre une liste de ce qui ne va pas
dans la police et par la même occasion
ouais et j'avais moi et a par la même
occasion si on pouvait le rencontrer on
serait vraiment honoré l'encontre étant
part directement à pithiviers
est ce que tu peux me dire juste au cas
où je te tutoie parce que terry
guillaume aussi on est devenus donc
voilà on s'envoie des cv sont des de
honte et voilà on a on a gardé contact
et guillaume parce que il m'a beaucoup
touché aussi et c'est vrai que ce qui
est arrivé à sa collègue m'a beaucoup
touché également donc on a on a beaucoup
échangé tous les deux hors antenne et
voilà pendant ces plusieurs jours
guillaume qu'elle est juste
j'aimerais que tu nous proposes une
proposition ce soir moi la proposition
je te le dis qu'il me semble quand même
la plus importante c'est mine de rien
aménager un autre cycle de travail pour
les policiers parce que c'est plus
possible et et craquer et sa greffe
usine envers dieu
un garçon sans merci
c'est compliqué cyril parce qu'on a une
police nationale et républicaine qui
avoue ses chalets ça et quand on voit
des suicides et les suicides des
celliers aussi aussi des recettes de
famille par rapport au rythme fou qu'ils
ont il ya énormément de divorce dans la
politisation et des familles qui sont
brisées de qu'il faut absolument mettre
fin à ce cycle infernal quoi c'est pas
possible il ya 21 millions d'heures
supplémentaires m payés pour les
factures de police sitting